Estas navidades de 2021 vamos a celebrar un
aniversario muy especial: se cumplen 30 años
de la caída del comunismo en la Unión Soviética.
Habéis oído bien.
El 25 de diciembre de 1991, el por entonces
presidente de la Unión Soviética, Mikhail
Gorvachev, dio este discurso.
(Tenemos mucho de todo: tierra, petróleo,
gas, otras riquezas naturales, y tampoco Dios
nos ofendió en cuanto a inteligencia y talentos.
Pero vivíamos bastante peor que en los países
desarrollados. La razón de esto era evidente.
La sociedad estaba asfixiada por las tenazas
de un sistema burocrático y autoritario.
Así no se podía seguir viviendo. Todo tenía
que cambiar radicalmente.)
En este discurso no sólo anunciaba su dimisión.
También anunciaba la desintegración de la
Unión Soviética… ¡Y el fin del comunismo!
No sé si os dais cuenta de la importancia
de este momento.
El comunismo en Rusia no cayó por una revuelta
popular ni tampoco por una guerra. Fue el
propio líder comunista el que un día dijo
“chicos… nos hemos dado cuenta de que
esto no funciona y que nos tenemos que hacer
capitalistas. Ale, Feliz Navidad”.
Muchos diréis ¡Pues menuda novedad! ¡Anda
que no se veía venir! Pero lo cierto es que,
hasta ese momento, la Unión Soviética era
la segunda potencia más importante del mundo.
Ni siquiera los más fervientes anticomunistas
se habrían imaginado que el comunismo fuera
a caer por su propio peso. Así que la pregunta
es ¿Por qué cayó el comunismo en la Unión
Soviética? En este vídeo lo vamos a ver.
(INTRO VISUALPOLITIK)
La Unión Soviética es como tus bisabuelos.
Posiblemente te han contado muchas cosas sobre
ellos pero en verdad no los has conocido o
apenas tienes recuerdos de ellos. Pues con
la Unión Soviética pasa lo mismo.
Todos sabemos que tenían un sistema comunista,
que ganaron en la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
después empezaron una guerra fría con Estados
Unidos.
Sin embargo, estos días se cumplen 30 años
de la disolución de la Unión Soviética.
Y hace un mes vimos un tweet de Bloomberg
con una frase del presidente chino que nos
llamó mucho la atención.
(Xi asegura que la Unión Soviética cayó
porque "nadie fue lo suficientemente hombre
para levantarse y resistir" a Estados Unidos)
Sabíamos que en la URSS había escasez de
muchas cosas pero... seamos honestos: la testosterona
no era una de ellas. Todos los que mandaban
eran hombres. En cualquier caso, así se pronunció
Xi Jinping en 2012 en un discurso meses antes
de convertirse en presidente de China.
Así que nos han entrado muchas ganas de hablar
de la URSS.
Queremos hacer un balance del comunismo soviético:
reconocer sus logros, que también los hubo,
y señalar sus errores.
Por supuesto, en este vídeo vamos a resumir
más de 80 años de historia en unos pocos
minutos, así que habrá muchos detalles que
no podremos cubrir. Por eso, hoy vamos a centrarnos
en una pregunta ¿Por qué cayó el comunismo?
¿Qué ocurrió para que, el 25 de diciembre
de 1991, el líder de una de las mayores superpotencias
del mundo dimitiera y anunciara todo un cambio
de sistema político?¿Por qué motivo fracasaron
las reformas de Gorbachov?
Hoy, en este especial soviético de VisualPolitik,
vamos a responder a estas preguntas. Pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
(EL NACIMIENTO DE UNA SUPERPOTENCIA)
En 1929, Estados Unidos sufrió la gran depresión.
Mientras todo el mundo capitalista estaba
inmerso en una crisis económica salvaje,
el Este comunista estaba en su edad de oro
¡Habéis oído bien! Rusia estaba pasando
de ser un país casi medieval y agrícola
en una potencia industrial.
De hecho, hay estimaciones que dicen que la
Unión Soviética era uno de los países que
más rápido estaban creciendo en todo el
mundo.
Y sí, digo estimaciones porque el PIB no
se empezó a utilizar como indicador macroeconómico
hasta 1937. Pero eso es otra historia.
Lo importante es que Rusia estaba “on fire”.
Y diréis ¿Pero cómo es eso posible? ¿No
se supone que el comunismo no funciona?
Pensadlo bien, hay algo peor que el comunismo
y es... la falta de sistema.
Hasta la revolución rusa, los zares se limitaban
a enlazar una guerra con otra. Y para financiarlas
se dedicaban a imprimir rublos y a exprimir
a sus súbditos recaudando impuestos.
De repente llegan los comunistas y el Estado
empieza a utilizar todo ese dinero que recauda
para invertir. De repente, los rusos tuvieron
educación, infraestructuras y sistemas de
producción más modernos.
El centralismo económico transfirió recursos
del campo a las ciudades.
(Los soviéticos creían que la industrialización
tenía que hacerse a gran escala para tener
éxito. La producción de las fábricas debía
ser lo suficientemente grande como para justificar
el alto coste inicial de construirlas. Por
eso, tras el primer plan quinquenal de Stalin,
en el año 1928, el capital invertido en industrializar
el país aumentó en un 336% La cantidad de
campesinos expulsados de las granjas e incorporados
a la industria creció en casi un 190%. Todo
esto cosechó buenos resultados, aunque ligeramente
por debajo de lo esperado: la producción
industrial creció un 170%.)
Stalin decía lo mismo que en Parque Jurásico.
¡No hemos reparado en gastos! Luego ya llegaron
los dinosaurios, pero de momento hay que ver
cómo lucía el Parque Soviético.
Eso sí, un problema grave es que la colectivización
agrícola no funcionó. Stalin trató de extraer
recursos de la agricultura por la fuerza y
aquello fue un desastre. Acabó con los kulaks,
que eran los agricultores más prósperos,
y nacionalizó los animales de tiro, lo que
provocó que fueran sacrificados por los granjeros.
El resultado habla por sí solo: la producción
agrícola disminuyó en más de una cuarta
parte en comparación con 1928. Pero Stalin
no era precisamente de esa clase de gobernantes
que tolera la crítica. La represión fue
terrible.
(El principal periódico soviético dice que
20 millones murieron como víctimas de Stalin)
Lo peor de los años 30 es que eras un don
nadie si no invadías otro país.
Así que a Stalin le pareció buena idea firmar
el pacto Molotov-Ribbentrop con la Alemania
nazi para repartirse la mitad de Polonia,
anexionarse las repúblicas bálticas y ocupar
Besarabia, que es la actual Moldavia. Luego
Hitler le traicionó y casi casi acaba con
la Unión Soviética porque a esas alturas
Stalin había hecho una purga brutal dentro
del Ejército Rojo, liquidando a prácticamente
todos sus altos mandos. Finalmente la victoria
en la Segunda Guerra Mundial confirmó a la
Unión Soviética como una de las dos grandes
superpotencias del globo. Comenzaba la Guerra
Fría.
(DE LA CIMA AL COLAPSO)
Seguro que todos lo habréis oído alguna
vez: el comunismo soviético no funcionaba
porque la gente no tenía incentivos para
trabajar ¿Es esto cierto? Pues sí... y a
la vez no.
Si seguís nuestro canal hermano, Megaprojekts,
ya conocéis muchos de los grandes avances
soviéticos.
La Unión Soviética podía presumir de tener
a muchas de las mentes más brillantes de
la historia. De hecho, durante los primeros
años de la carrera espacial, Rusia llevaba
bastante ventaja a Estados Unidos.
Por aquel entonces se tenía en Occidente
una sensación parecida a la que hoy día
se tiene con China. Había un miedo real a
que los Soviéticos superasen económicamente
y militarmente a Estados Unidos y, en general,
el mundo capitalista.
Pensadlo bien: apenas había información
sobre lo que ocurría al otro lado del telón
de acero. Y el aparato de censura soviético
se encargaba muy bien de tapar sus vergüenzas.
Y lo cierto es que había muchas vergüenzas
que tapar. Podríamos decir que, a mediados
de los años 60 es cuando el comunismo soviético
empieza a agotarse.
La aparición del petróleo en Siberia ofreció
un respiro al Partido Comunista.
En cualquier caso, el problema de la economía
soviética es que tenía una productividad
muy reducida. La URSS se estaba quedando estancada
en los años 70. Y diréis... ¿Pero por qué?
¿Dónde está el problema? Y aquí es donde
entra en escena uno de los pocos economistas
que SÍ predijeron el colapso del Comunismo
Soviético. Y lo hizo varias décadas antes
de que ocurriera: hablamos de .
En su obra “El Socialismo”, Mises explica
las principales diferencias entre una economía
centralizada y una economía libre.
En una economía libre, los empresarios encuentran
ineficiencias que intentan resolver. Algunos
aciertan y se hacen ricos. Otros fracasan
y desaparecen. Pero, en general, el capital
tiende a concentrarse en los sectores más
eficientes ¿Y cómo se sabe cuales son los
sectores más eficientes? Mediante el sistema
de precios.
Si yo veo que el precio de un bien es muy
alto, es porque existe mucha demanda de ese
bien: es decir, que hace falta más oferta.
Sin embargo, en una economía centralizada,
el capital no se reparte bajo criterios económicos
sino políticos.
Es decir, el estado puede invertir en sectores
que no necesariamente son los más eficientes.
Eso explica que un régimen socialista pueda
tener éxito en el corto plazo.
El estado gasta a manos llenas y puede incluso
crear sectores que de otro modo serían impensables
¿Un ejemplo?
La industria pesada en un país como Rusia,
que venía de ser un país agrícola ¿El
problema? Que, a la larga, empiezan a surgir
deficiencias que no se detectan porque no
hay competencia ni exigencia de responsabilidades.
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Os doy un ejemplo:
la historia del Mar de Aral.
(El Mar de Aral era antiguamente uno de los
4 lagos más grandes del mundo. En los años
60, la Unión Soviética hizo un montón de
trasvases para llevar toda esa agua a los
campos de cultivo de algodón. Todo esto habría
sido prácticamente imposible de hacer en
un país capitalista. El estado habría tenido
que pasar años de litigios para hacerse con
todas las propiedades.
Y el precio de todos esos terrenos sería
tan caro que, al final, se habrían hecho
sólo unos pequeños trasvases.
Sin embargo, en un país comunista, no existe
propiedad privada sobre la tierra. Así que
alguien en una oficina de Moscú decidió
que había que hacer un megatrasvase de un
día para otro.
De repente, el lago quedó reducido a un 10%
de su tamaño original. Además del desastre
ecológico que esto supone, también hay un
desastre económico. Lo que podía ser una
zona perfecta para el cultivo, ahora está
prácticamente desierto.)
Ahora imaginad este ejemplo replicado en mil
y un otro casos. La historia de la Unión
Soviética es la historia de montones de proyectos
megalómanos.
Ciudades como Magnitogorsk, por ejemplo, que
fueron creadas de un día para otro. Muchos
de estos proyectos no tenían porqué ser
malas ideas.
El problema era que, al no tener un sistema
de precios, no sabían cuántos recursos había
que invertir para que realmente tuvieran sentido
económico.
Si a eso le sumamos la falta de libertad de
expresión, tenemos que nadie se atrevía
a señalar las ineficiencias ¿Conclusión?
Lo que en un momento fue una de las economías
de más rápido crecimiento del mundo, terminó
estancándose.
La crisis del petróleo de 1979 disparó el
precio del crudo, lo que volvió a inyectar
montones y montones de dólares a la economía
soviética. Eso hizo que el Politburó se
viniera arriba y a alguien del Kremlin le
pareciera una buena idea invadir Afganistán.
Hoy día ya sabemos que incursionar por Kabul
y alrededores es ir directos al precipicio.
Los soviéticos no escaparon de la trampa
afgana.
De repente se vieron envueltos en una espiral
continua de aumento del gasto militar. Pero
ojo que la culpa no fue solo de los afganos.
Ronald Reagan también tuvo muc ho que ver.
(Mentiras y pruebas manipuladas de 'Star Wars'
engañaron al Kremlin y al Congreso)
No era tan potente como la Estrella de la
Muerte, pero Reagan se sacó de la manga un
escudo espacial para protegerse de un ataque
nuclear que desató el pánico en el Kremlin.
Los dirigentes comunistas se pusieron a gastar
millones y millones en intentar replicar algo
que sencillamente era imposible porque no
era más que una burla estadounidense. Esta
estafa supuso la ruina absoluta para la economía
de la URSS. Estaba clara la cuestión que
entonces estaba sobre la mesa: ¿Era demasiado
tarde para intentar cambiar a la Unión Soviética?
Ahora mismo lo vemos.
(LA PERESTROIKA)
La Unión Soviética llegó a los años 80
con la vieja guardia a los mandos. Se había
convertido en toda una gerontocracia. La edad
promedio de los miembros del Politburó era
de 70 años frente a los 55 que tenían cuando
murió Stalin.
Y hombre, la experiencia es un grado pero
también tiene sus riesgos. En menos de 3
años murieron 3 secretarios generales del
Partido Comunista: Brézhnev, Andrópov y
Chernenko. El régimen daba muestras de descomposición.
(La corrupción asolaba al Kremlin. Se acababa
de descubrir el Gran Escándalo del Algodón,
que implicaba directamente a uno de los peces
gordos del Politburó. No era un caso aislado:
los escándalos de los dirigentes comunistas
ya no los podía tapar ni la peor censura.)
Así que los reformistas estaban cargados
de razones cuando en 1985 consiguieron la
designación de Mijail Gorbachov como máximo
dirigente de la Unión Soviética. Visto lo
visto, era todo un chaval. Tenía 54 años
y muchas ganas de cambiar las cosas. Trató
de hacerlo desde el principio pero enseguida
sus reformas tuvieron que hacer frente a la
gran prueba de fuego: el peor accidente nuclear
de la Historia. Chernobyl dejó una vez más
en evidencia la falta de transparencia de
las autoridades soviéticas. 20 años después
de la catástrofe el propio Gorbachov lo tenía
claro.
(El accidente nuclear de Chernobyl, incluso
más que mi lanzamiento de la perestroika,
fue quizás la principal causa del colapso
de la Unión Soviética cinco años después.
Mijaíl Gorbachov. Abril de 2006)
El encubrimiento de Chernobyl fue letal para
la URSS. Las autoridades soviéticas tardaron
varios días en informar del accidente. Los
primeros datos sobre la catástrofe llegaron
desde Suecia, donde se detectó un aumento
de la radiactividad. Así que la gente de
Ucrania y del resto de Europa del Este estuvo
haciendo vida normal sin saber que se estaban
exponiendo a lo peor de la nube radiactiva.
Aquello fue para Gorbachov una muestra de
que el sistema soviético necesitaba reformas
más profundas que las ya iniciadas.
Estas se hicieron bajo la bandera de la perestroika,
que significa reestructuración en ruso. Englobó
un conjunto de medidas diseñadas para liberalizar
poco a poco la economía y el sistema político.
Se dieron pasos hacia un mercado libre limitado
y hacia la descentralización de la economía
soviética. Una parte importante de estas
reformas fueron la glasnot, que significa
transparencia.
La prensa y la televisión empezaron a incluir
posturas contrarias al proyecto socialista.
Todo esto condujo a celebrar en 1989 unas
elecciones relativamente libres que dejaron
definitivamente en evidencia que el Partido
Comunista estaba completamente desacreditado
ante los ciudadanos.
(Los votantes soviéticos ofrecen un golpe
humillante a los candidatos oficiales del
Partido)
La caída del Muro de Berlín a finales de
1989 fue el primer signo de que el bloque
comunista empezaba a desmoronarse. A lo largo
de 1990 se celebraron elecciones legislativas
en cada una de las 15 repúblicas socialistas
soviéticas. Por primera vez la oposición
al Kremlin tenía libertad para poder decir
lo que el Politburó del Partido Comunista
no quería escuchar. Así que había llegado
la oportunidad que los nacionalistas de cada
una de las repúblicas estaban esperando.
Las tres repúblicas bálticas no perdieron
ni un segundo para iniciar su transición
a la independencia.
Otros territorios reivindicaban su propia
soberanía, como la república soviética
rusa liderada por Boris Yeltsin. La desintegración
de la URSS había iniciado su cuenta atrás.
Todo se aceleró en agosto de 1991 con el
fallido golpe de Estado dado por la KGB y
el ala dura del Partido Comunista. No había
vuelta atrás. Las repúblicas socialistas
soviéticas decidieron acabar con la URSS.
En su discurso de renuncia como presidente
de la Unión Soviética, Gorbachov expuso
el fracaso absoluto del comunismo.
(Tenemos mucho de todo: tierra, petróleo,
gas, otras riquezas naturales, y tampoco Dios
nos ofendió en cuanto a inteligencia y talentos.
Pero vivíamos bastante peor que en los países
desarrollados. La razón de esto era evidente.
La sociedad estaba asfixiada por las tenazas
de un sistema burocrático y autoritario.
Así no se podía seguir viviendo. Todo tenía
que cambiar radicalmente.)
Desmantelar la Unión Soviética era lo último
en lo que pensaba Gorbachov. Creía que el
régimen comunista podía avanzar hacia una
socialdemocracia que contara con el apoyo
de la gente.
Pero después de décadas bajo el yugo del
poder soviético, cuando a la gente le das
la oportunidad de pronunciarse lo único que
quieren es algo muy sencillo: quieren libertad.
(La verdad era simple: la Unión Soviética
era imposible de reformar. El 25 de diciembre
de 1991 su bandera era arriada en el Kremlin.
Punto final para la hoz y el martillo. En
su lugar empezó a ondear la bandera tricolor
de la Federación Rusa.)
¡Y muchos diréis! ¿Y qué pasó después?
¿De verdad le ha ido bien a Rusia con el
capitalismo? Pues de eso hablaremos en otro
vídeo que sacaremos próximamente.
Mientras tanto, la pregunta es para vosotros:
¿Creéis que la Unión Soviética podía
haber evitado su disolución? Y lo que es
más importante ¿Qué pensáis de Gorvachov?
¿De verdad fue un héroe de la democracia
como muchos quieren ver? ¿O tal vez fue una
víctima de los acontecimientos?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas. Así que
suscribíos al canal para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. ¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!